what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
discussing a massive twist in the boku
no hero story a twist which revealed
something incredibly important about one
of the first villains that we met in the
series way back in the first season of
the anime and chapter 11 of the manga
but beyond this recent twist which
revealed Kudo Gary's shocking secret
identity in this video I will also be
explaining why Kudo GT is going to
become a far more important character
than we may have thought at first glance
in fact I believe that Kudo Gary will be
a major player in the coming arcs of the
boku no hero story and both his quirk
and his secret identity will turn out to
be important factors in the very near
future if you enjoy the boku no hero
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications be sure to follow us on
Twitch twitch.tv slash anime uproar we
stream chapter discussions every week
for boku no hero and a bunch of other
manga series so definitely check us out
link in the description and in case
you'd prefer to listen to our videos in
audio format as a podcast you can now do
that just look for anime uproar audio
wherever you get your podcasts or you
can just click the direct link in the
description to follow us on Spotify
Apple podcasts or a bunch of others
podcast platforms finally this video
will contain boku no hero manga spoilers
we're dealing with the latest
developments in the boku no hero story
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned up until the most recent
chapters of the boku no hero story
here's what we knew about kudo kitty he
is a member of the League of villains
who is fiercely loyal to all for one and
who spent most of his time basically
babysitting shigaraki
and making sure that she got Aki doesn't
get himself killed
his name kudo giri means black fog and
it appears as if his entire body is
either made up of or completely covered
in a dark fog like substance kudo
kitties biggest strength
this is absolutely amazing quark called
warp gate this quark is classified as an
extremely rare type of quark and it
allows scooter Getty to create portals
out of the black fog that surrounds his
body he can then use these portals to
teleport objects and people to another
location or to bring objects and people
from another location to his current
location along with big portals that can
teleport entire people or even groups of
people at once
guru Kitty can also generate a bunch of
small portals at the same time portals
big enough to transport a part of
someone's body but not their entire body
we saw this way back when Dhabi and toga
first met shigaraki and they all nearly
killed each other
guru kitty was able to diffuse the
situation by using his portals to make
their hands appear in different places
from where they had intended thereby
preventing them from actually hurting
each other
Kudo Kitty can use the fog that
surrounds him to hide his own body
although his body is always in there
somewhere so if his opponent can find it
they can potentially take him down
before he uses his quirk the only major
limitation of his quirk is that he must
know the exact location in which the
portals are going to open so for example
he cannot simply choose to teleport into
deck whose bathroom and kill him on the
toilet unless he knows the exact
coordinates of that bathroom but despite
his amazing and highly versatile quirk
guru Gary was somehow captured by gran
torino and su kouchi back in chapter 1 6
2 they found him as a result of some
very convenient eyewitness reports so
arguably the most stealthy and evasive
villain in the entire series a villain
who can literally teleport at will was
spotted by a random eyewitness and
successfully arrested as a result after
the arrest Kudo GT was taken to the
maximum-security prison called Tartarus
where all the most dangerous villains
are currently being held including of
course
all-4-one kudo kitty is being sedated
inside the prison so that he cannot use
his teleporting quirk to escape and once
that happened for many chapters kudo
Gettys seemed to become completely
irrelevant to the story he was just
another prisoner in Tartarus and the
League of villains had to carry on
without
help but then in Chapter 253 it was
revealed that Kudo GD is not just any
criminal who happened to join the league
of villains at some point no the truth
is much darker than that Kuro Giri is
actually a highly advanced nomal a nomu
that was created by all-4-one energy
coal using the corpse of Eraserhead and
present mike's childhood friend
Oboro shirokuma Oberto shirokuma was a
classmate or a razor head and present
mike bat when they were students in ua
and the three of them were best friends
and extremely close they were planning
on opening a hero office together after
they graduated and they were just
beginning to get real-world experience
as part of their hero work Studies
program when tragedy struck during a
fight against a massive villain Oboro
sheer Akuma was killed all burrows death
had a major impact on Eraserhead and
present mike and they struggled for a
long time to come to terms with it
however it turns out that the story of
Oboro sheer Akuma did not actually end
with his alleged death the arch villain
all-4-one had somehow managed to get his
hands on a burrows corpse and with the
help of Daruma ug co they were able to
use obras body as a base in order to
create the highly advanced normal known
as kudo giddy oberus quirk cloud appears
to have been used as a base for the
creation of kudo Geary's quirk warpgate
all for one used his unique ability to
combine various quirks into one in order
to create what we know today as warpgate
so this overpowered an incredibly rare
perk was not unnaturally occurring quirk
it was artificially created by all-4-one
upon his creation the nomal kudo giddy
was programmed to take care of shigaraki
and to help him become a worthy
successor to all-4-one after kudo giddy
is arrested and imprisoned in Tartarus
the connection between him and Oberoi is
discovered through DNA testing
apparently the base quark which was used
to create a warp gate was open original
were called cloud Oh burrows quark
enabled him to create and control clouds
and he was even able to fly on top of
the clouds that he created he could also
use his quark to give himself cloud
cover basically he could use the clouds
to severely reduce the visibility for
his opponents and to hide his own body
within the clouds this is of course very
similar to Kudo Gettys ability to hide
his own body within his black mist by
the way Oh Boris quark and character
design appeared to be a direct reference
to Sun Wukong The Monkey King from the
famous Chinese novel Journey to the West
if any of this sounds familiar it's
because son Goku from Dragon Ball was
also directly inspired by Journey to the
West as was his famous flying Nimbus the
flying cloud Eraserhead and present mic
are summoned to Tartarus and there they
learned that Kudo GD is a normal created
from the corpse of their deceased best
friend the two heroes are visibly
shocked but they decide to try to speak
to Kudo GD in order to determine whether
their friend Oboro is still in there
somewhere
at first guru kitty does not recall
anything about his former life but iowa
becomes emotional and cries out to Oboro
begging him to wake up so that the three
of them can become heroes together like
they always dreamed eventually o burrows
personality does seem to break through
from the inside and we see a glimpse of
Oberoi's face poking through Kudo
Geary's mist he is able to say something
about a hospital a potential clue for
how he ended up as kuru kitty but then
kuru kitty loses consciousness and Oboro
is unable to provide any more
information it seems that the normal
kudo giri was programmed to basically
short-circuit if he ever starts giving
up information that could in any way
jeopardize all for one's plans this is
what we know so far as of the making of
this video and I have to say that all of
this is extremely interesting
information the stuff that Oboro said
about a hospital is probably a clue as
to how he ended up a normal in the first
place my guess is that Oboro was trying
to tell his friends that at some point
after his body was taken to the hospital
he was abducted by the doctor Daruma
Fujiko aunt
turned into a normal with the help of
all-4-one the big question is was Oboro
really dead when his body was taken to
the hospital or was he actually still
alive but Yugi Qin all for one made it
look like he died so that they could use
Oboro for their normal experiments my
personal guess is that Oboro was
probably on the brink of death but still
alive and I will explain why here's a
really important question how is it
possible that kuru Guinea is such a
highly advanced normal and yet he was
created so long ago
we've only recently seen the high-end
gnome who begin to make their appearance
and hood was the first normal we saw
that was capable of somewhat coherent
speech and yet we are supposed to
believe that kudo GD was created like 14
or 15 years ago and yet he is by far the
most advanced nomal that we have ever
seen
not only does kudo GD have an amazing
quirk but his intelligence and capacity
for coherent speech are on a completely
different level from even the high and
Noble the gnomon that are not high-end
are just mindless machines of
destruction and can't even be compared
to kudo giddy and even though the Heian
normal like hood do appear to have a
personality of their own again their
intelligence cannot be compared to kudo
giddy I mean the fact that we didn't
even know that kuru giddy wasn't normal
until it was explicitly confirmed says a
lot there is no way that we could have
mistaken any other nomu for anything but
a normal and yet kuru giddy is just so
different from the most advanced normal
that we have seen so much more
intelligent and coherent as a person how
were all for one a new G Co able to
create such an advanced and intelligent
no move 14 or 15 years ago
and yet they cannot seem to duplicate
that process today one would assume that
their research would only have
progressed further in the last 14 or 15
years not regressed the only answer for
this that I can think of is Kudo Geary's
base Oboro shirokuma
the other nomu may be built from corpses
but i believe that kuru get his base
Oboro wasn't actually dead when he was
turned into a nomal I think he was
severely injured and on the verge of
death but his death was then falsified
in the hospital with the help of
a no burros body was then used to create
kudo giddy while Oboro was still alive I
would guess that using live subjects to
create nomu instead of corpses is what
allows a normal to be far more advanced
and intelligent than a regular normal
and this is what I think happened to
kudo kitty in fact the procedure that
you gqo recently performed on shigaraki
who is of course alive is probably just
an advanced version of the procedure
that was performed on Oboro
in order to create kudo giddy but beyond
the emotional aspect of kuru get his
true identity being the childhood friend
of Aizawa and present mike i think that
kuru kitty is going to become an
increasingly important character for the
plot as a whole back when he was first
arrested I made a video stating that I
don't think that kudo godis sudden
arrest was just a lucky break for the
police kudo giddy was located due to
some very convenient eyewitness reports
and then he was taken to Tartarus the
same place where all for one and many
other major villains are being held
that's right thanks to his arrest the
guy whose quirk allows him to create
portals and teleport himself and others
somewhere far away is now in the same
exact location as his prison master and
therefore kudo Giri now just happens to
be in the ideal position to break his
master all-4-one out of prison now you
may be thinking well kuru Giri is being
kept under maximum security conditions
and his jailers are preventing him from
using his quirk by keeping him
unconscious but don't forget that all
for one can forcibly activate the quirks
of others and in the past he actually
forcibly activated kuru Gettys own quirk
back when kuru kitty was knocked
unconscious during the hideout ray dark
so as long as all for one can find a way
to somehow free himself inside the
prison he will be able to teleport out
of it using warp gate whether or not
kudo giddy is conscious not to mention
that all for one already has a ton of
other quirks that will be extremely
useful for him if he really is planning
a prison break
including the quark called search which
he stole from ragdoll this quirk enables
the user to monitor the position and
weak points of up to 100 people in a
given
area and you can imagine how useful such
a quirk would be during a prison break
if you're trying to escape from prison
being able to monitor the exact position
and weak points of every guard in jail
is a pretty damn useful ability so in my
humble opinion all of this stuff about
kudo giddy being a borough is more than
just a way for us to learn about Iowa's
backstory and getting some more
character development for everyone's
favorite you a teacher I believe that
this massive reveal about kudo giddy is
just a lead-up to a big prison break arc
that all for one is planning after all
all for one still hasn't given shigaraki
all of the powers that he was intending
to give him before he got arrested
so I think that all for one has both the
means and the motive to break out of
prison and of course the key to him
gaining the means to break out was the
capture and arrest of kudo kitty don't
forget that kudo Gettys warpgate is
limited by the fact that the user needs
to know the exact physical coordinates
of every location that he wants to
teleport to and since Tartarus is a
top-secret prison it is likely that the
only way that kudo getti could have
learned the location of Tartarus was to
get himself arrested on purpose but let
me know what you guys think how do you
feel about the big kudo giddy identity
reveal and why do you think that even
though Oboro was supposed to have died
like 14 years ago the no moon that was
created out of him is way more advanced
than any Nomo that we have seen to date
also do you agree with me that an all
for one prison-break arc is coming and
that his plan for breaking out will
involve the use of kudo GD and his quark
hit me up down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more boku no hero content right here
on the channel please leave a like to
let me know it really helps and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you could also hit me up
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
I want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons who support our
work and make videos like this one
possible with all the problems facing
YouTube right now patrons are more
important than ever and we really
appreciate it
special thank you to our pro hero to
your patron
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
drous Fanny dolla beat Anatoly Cassatt's
ki alpha do on hell crews and team
Sparky 65 and I can't forget the ones
who rise above all other clans a massive
thank you to our the one and tear
patrons including ingrid ah alone out of
Merrimack makoto-kun the world Steelers
and the school bus if you enjoy our
videos and you feel they provide value
for you please consider becoming a
patron even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]